you truly cannot write this stuff
another Republican I'm not talking now
about George Anthony devolder Santos I'm
talking about a different Republican who
claimed Jewish Heritage and it turns out
she's not only lying
her grandfather was a Nazi uh I it's it
what a world that we live in article
from the Jerusalem Post
congresswoman claims to be Jewish
revealed to be the granddaughter of a
Nazi we are talking about new Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna
she has claimed Jewish Heritage
previously and it turns out her
grandfather Heinrich mayerhoffer and
this is not the this is not like a jack
Maya Hoffer moment the when Bill
O'Reilly got pranked by that this is
genuinely the guy's name Heinrich
mayerhoffer who died in 2003 served in
the armed forces of Nazi Germany when he
was a teenager in the 40s you really
should read this entire J Post article
it's wild wild stuff Florida Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna was
outed by The Washington Post Friday for
lying about her Jewish Heritage in a
previous interview with the Jewish
Insider not only is Luna almost
certainly not Jewish but according to
several family members according to the
post Luna's paternal grandfather
Heinrich mayerhoffer who died in 2003
served in the armed forces of Nazi
Germany as a teenager in the 40s Luna
had told the Jewish Insider I was raised
as a Messianic Jew by my father
clarifying she identifies as a Christian
I am also a small fraction Nazi now
she's speaking ethnically of course
The Insider had interviewed Luna in
reaction to the fact that Marjorie
Taylor Green known for her Jewish space
laser conspiracy endorsed Luna's
candidacy if she were anti-semitic asked
Luna after claiming Ashkenazi Roots why
did she endorse me
I in no way shape or form would ever put
myself in a position where I'm hanging
out with someone like that and so I just
don't see that Marjorie Taylor green is
that person if I see it happening on the
right I'm the first person to condemn it
and say like hey that's not cool I don't
align with that reminiscent of Hillary
Clinton's I told Wall Street to cut it
out which they laughed about but now
this is taken seriously Luna has also
invoked Nazis in her political rhetoric
in 2021 she tweeted a video insinuating
that a registry of Americans who were
not vaccinated against covid would be
like the Nazi list of Jews
um this is very very quickly becoming
another George Santos situation as the
lies are piling up now some people wrote
to me and said David you know sure she's
a liar but like what's so bad about
saying you're one religion when you're
just not that religion like David if you
said you were Baptist and you weren't
Baptist it wouldn't really be offensive
it would be a lie but it would be
offensive it wouldn't be offensive you
really have to understand what Judaism
is
being Jewish is not just a religion
Judaism is a cultural identity if you
were if you didn't convert into Judaism
you're also ethnically Jewish like when
I did my DNA came back oh David you're
Ashkenazi that's an ethnicity I could
change my beliefs into whatever
Mormonism I'd still be ethnically Jewish
and there's a history ethnically and
culturally in addition to religiously
which has faced centuries of persecution
really Millennia it's an ethno-religious
group and so when you falsely claim
Jewish Heritage you're not only erasing
the experiences and the struggles of
actual Jewish people you also perpetuate
stereotypes you're participating in
cultural appropriation so it's not like
a harmless act it is deception it is a
lie at the end of the day but it's a
particular type of lie that under
undermines trust and respect so George
Santos George Anthony devolder Santos
did this falsely claiming Jewish
Heritage Anna Paulina Luna has done it
and then lastly there's one other
wrinkle here
pretending to be Jewish and then
exonerating Marjorie Taylor green
ferment accusations of anti-Semitism
with your fake jewishness is like
another particularly disgusting layer to
the entire thing so it is not only
Santos that is participating in these
and many other lies if you're curious
about Luna's other lies there's a number
of articles about it now which you can
find
ugly ugly stuff we're going to take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel make
sure you're subscribed to the Spanish
YouTube channel what what David what are
you talking about later on in the show
I'll tell you all about what's going on
in Spanish
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
to real paper you'll get 30 off your
first order plus free shipping go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below